AND WE START WITR
HE
IT IS  SAVOFF IS FOR MORE PEOPID
CORONAVIRUS CASES IN
STATES IS UPFROM THI
TIME LAST WEEK.
SOUTHATETHE SURGE WE'RE
NOW, WHI B
THE UNVACCEDRSE TH
HOIKFR
LAST SPRING.
L OF THESE
RN,
CAS CA
LY PACOFIORTS.
>> Reporter: AS TH HEALTH CRISIS
WORSE, THE WARNINGS TO THE
UNINNG
IN ALABAMA THE STATE WITH TH
COUNTR 34%.RATE IN THE
NEW CASESN COVID ARE
THE UNVACCINATED FOLE RT BLAMIN
IT'S THE UACD FOLKS THAT
ARE LETTING US DOWN. REPUBLICA
KAY IVY  UP.
>> THESE FOLG A
HORRIBLE LIFESTYLE
SE
>> I DON'T KNOW.ING TO TAKE TO
YOLLE.
ED
NTAGIOUS DEL
SUPERCHARGAD, N PLACES WITW IONT
VEOR
CORONAVIS INFECTIONS A DAY ANG .
CASES UP 65% OVER JUST
EK, AND ALMOST FOUR TIMES
HIGHER
D HOSPITALIZIOIS
SEVEN DAYS.NWIDE IN JUST
LY PACOFLL AMONG THE
VACCATE NTJANUARY, D
IALS ARE BEGGING
THE UNVACCINATED TECT LVES.
EEMS LIKE WE'RE JUST
FIGHTI LOSING LE HERepHEMORE THT
INFECTIONSMO AREFULFILVACCINATE.
STILL, DOCTORS STRESS. AKTHROUG
FE
I'VE SN  PRACTICE,
SOT IT'S MILD ILLN
AND THAT'SHA DO.
AND WITH MILLIONS OF CBACK TO
, A CN FINDSBLE
KIDSE FULL
VACCINATED AINID IN
WEEKSD  SCHOOLS I
ATLANTA, WASHINGTON, D.C., ARE
NE.
>>SHOULD HAVE TH
FEARS. ARE SIMPLY  R
I OOL BOARD VERSAL Mr: EXP AUE>
E ASKING PAR
FULL BASICALLYO
STATUS. HARD EORNATION -MAARING
>> Reporter: NOW, ALONG WITH
ALABAMA, MISSISSIPPIS THE ONLYSO
PUAND HAN ADDITIONAL ROUGHLY 5
COMMUNITY PROFILE REPORTST UP F
PUBLISHED BY WHITE HESPONS
ME ATHENA JONES, THANKOUO
MUCH.
SCHAFFNESOT
UNIVERSITY M CENTER.
DR. SCHAFFNER, YOROUINATED
PEOPLE FOR THE RISE IN ANDIGHTO?
>>'T KNOW ABOU
INNLY CT.
COE UNVACCINATEDPLE WHO ARE
OF THEM.
ARE KEEPI CCE OUOFHOSPITAL.
ES DELTA V
SPREADING PRINCIPALLY AMON
VACCINATED
D YN UNVACCINATED?CNT TO
THAT CORRECTLY
>>OR
THERE ARLE I
INTENSIVE CARE UNITS WHO GIV
TO ABSOLUTELY
ERTIENT, PEOPLE WHO CRAS
NGS.
BU'RINGRUMPY APE COMIN
IN WITH COVID BECAUSE TH W
UNVAATTA
THEY DON'TEAY UNDERSTAND
TH SO, JUSTO BUTTON
THISP,N Y VACCINATED IAT FIRST
ARE WILLINGLATED.
'T HUCEDICALSSUES ORS WHO
ILUNVACCINEDE
CC RIGHT NOW? THE PEOPLE WHO AR
LY.SPILLOVER  ED
FORTUNATELY,HEY TENDEASE.NOR IN.
ED WOUT OM TWO WEEKS TO
>> BOTTOD IT'S NOT THEUGH CASE
HRGH UNVACCINATED CHDRSO THAT'SR
AT THIINHEANPE , DO YOU WANT
MANDATES?
NK TINO P HERE AA
LOCAL LEVEPENDIN THE LOISSION A
>> IT WILL.
AND I THINK THE REALITY IS THOS
BUT LET'S TALK ABOUT AS WE LK
WHERE WE ARE,
WHERE ARE WE HEADING.S AND OTHE
GET E IN THE WINTE
'RG A N CASES
NOW  ISU DOES
AT TO COMEN
>>NCERNED FLWIBACK
WITHTER RESPIRATORY
LOTF RESPIRATORY
ILLNESS.
THERE WIUI C
'S GOTWHO'S
D SPEAKING OF THE  WOBER COMPLST
AGAIN OR EXPECT THATPPENAGAIN.
BECAUSE D AT HOME,
WE SOCIAL DISTANCED, WE WO
MASKS, A PTHE
VIRUS, AND D T. SVIRU
THEN BRINGT HOMER
RS
NOW THAT SCHOOLS ARE OPENING U
OUOFF, BACK
BUSINESS, WE'RGOINE  AYOU'REOIT
DOUBLE WHAMMY, FLU AND THIS
VIRUS, ASSUMING THAT M
AREN'T GOIO
IN TIME, WE N'RETURN TO
IMMUNITY BY THAT
YOU HAVE KIDS WHO ARBE
LIGIBLE TO GET
N ANALYSISEME ON TRACK TO BEED S
WH IF TEENS.AGE TO TM AND
R PARENTS?
MAGE IS SIMPLE.
12 AND OLDER, PLEASE GET
VACCINATED, MAKE T OWNY,UR FAMI.
TALT ANOTHE
HOTOTODAY.E NFL.
EFO GET MORE
THE NFTE
HAVE TO FORFEIT A GAME, EVEN CID
FOGO
VACCINATED WHO FEEL LIKE THEY'RE
ELSE'S DECISION?
ISPE .